فعلا راويه المشهد وحده يعبر عن حاله هي
الان اصبحت هاتاي اصبحت مدينه ركام يعني
شبه كامله كل بناياتها واقعه على الارض
سواء كانت المعدات قد تدخلت عليها هذه
المعدات الثقيله وقامت بكسر بكسرها ليتمكن
يتمكن من رفعها على اماكن الشاحنات واخراج
الانقاض بعيدا عن المدينه ام ليس بعد لانه
الدمار هائل جدا هنا وعدد البنايات كبير
جدا فيحتاج الى اشهر لكي
تبدا عمليه يعني التصفيه هذه المساحات
الشاسعه من هذا الدمار الهائل يعني هناك
اعمال مستمره وجهود تبدا من اول لحظه بزوغ
الشمس والى غايه ساعات متاخره من الليل في
محاولات لازاحه هذه المش القاتمه والمروعه
للضحايا لمن نجوا من الموت من تحت هذا
الركام وهم يسكنون في خيام غير بعيده عن
هذه المشاهد للاسف فهناك مساعي لازاله هذه
الاثار برنامج انمائي للامم المتحده تحدث
عن ان او في تقديراته الاوليه بان كميات
هذه الاطنان قدرت بنحو مليوني طن من
الانقاض وكانت قد طرحت مخططا لمساعده
الحكومه التركيه
يعني محاوله الاستفاده من هذه الازمه في
حد ذاتها باعاده تدوير ما يمكن تدويره من
مضمون هذه الانقاذ من حديد من نحاس من
بلاستيك من مختلف يعني
الامور التي يمكن استرجاعها وطرحت فكره
تشغيل ابناء المنطقه
للاستفاده من ذلك هناك عمليات المسح ما
تزال مستمره ومتواصله
مبدئيا تم مسح حوالي 80% من المباني في
بعض المناطق بعينها وفق تصريحات وزاره
الداخليه التركيه يعني تحديد فيها مليون
و250 الف بنايه تم فحصها تم الاعلان عن ان
نصف مليون او اكثر من نصف مليون بنايه يا
اما تهدمت يا اما هي واجب تهديمها في اسرع
وقت تحسبا لاي هزه ارتداديه جديده وخوفا
من وقوعها على رؤوس المنقذين والعمال
ارتفاع لعدد الهزات الارتداديه حيث تجاوزت
9000 هز ارتداديه منذ الزلزال الاول
على سبيل المثال عادت لتفتح محالها
واسواقها التي لم الضرر هل هنالك اي مظاهر
للحياه عادت الى هاتاي من ناحيه الحياه
الاعتياديه يعني سوق محال
لا يمكن رصد هذا هذا الامر هنا فيها تاي
لانها مدينه منكوبه بالكامل
سوقها القديم وحتى الجديد مهدم بشكل كبير
جدا كانت لنا جوله في السوق يعني رايناه
في صوره يعني مخيفه ومرعبه جدا مختلفه
المحال والمباني القديمه والعتيقه المساجد
هذه المدينه التي تعرف تناغما من حيث يعني
الطوائف التي تعيش هنا هناك المسلمين هناك
مسيحيين حتى من بين المسلمين هناك عده
طوائف تتعايش فيما بينها الان لم يعد
اي من هذه المظاهر باديه للعيان فقط ما
نشاهده الان دمار هائل وبين الدمار
والدمار دمار اخر وبينهما بعض من الخيام
التي تاوي الناجين قد نشاهد الان من هذا
الجانب هذه الخيام لا ادري كيف يقضي
الناجون اوقاتهم وهم يعيشون على بعد امتار
قليله فقط من المباني والاحياء التي كانت
تاويهم سابقا وكانوا يعيشون فيها حياتهم
الان تحولت حياتهم
بنسبه كبيره جدا وغير مسبوقه يشاهدون ما
يجري امامهم لكنهم لا يحركون ساكنا نلاحظ
بين الفينه والاخرى بعض من الاسر ياتون
يقفون على هذا الركام قبل قليل شاهدت
عائله تحاول اخراج بعض يعني مقتنيات
والاغراض من تحت بناء لا يبدو منه الا
حوالي
ويخاطرون بانفسهم بالدخول ومحاوله اخراج
بعض الاغراض ويعني ما يذكرهم في الحياه
التي كانوا يعيشونها رغم تحذيرات السلطات
والرجال الامن